[Music]
one california couple is saying buyer
beware of timeshares the eight news now
i-team vanessa murphy looking into why
we took our daughters places
and no one has gone and you know the ski
resorts the betty malls have fond
memories of their travels from
california to places like hawaii tahiti
and las vegas we wanted to part of the
american dream we have three daughters
we wanted a vacation they say in 1998
they signed up for a time share but
according to nevada's consumer affairs
division what they actually purchased
was a vacation club a time share is
defined as buying into a single property
to visit each year while a vacation club
includes packages to choose from the
betty malls were under the impression
they were owners they say they upgraded
throughout the years and with each
vacation there was another sales pitch
we noticed one thing vanessa is that the
the time share presentations became more
pressured in 2021 i said no several
times they say they signed up for a
larger package with diamond resorts
these are these two phrases that they
use the sales presentation happy wife
happy life
alan you see my chart it's a no-brainer
so those type of expressions
turn to me
oh happy wife it's no-brainer i'm
thinking
yeah i
make her happy while there's a cost for
points to use toward vacations there's
also a maintenance fee the betty malls
claim they were told if they bought a
larger package they could use their
points to pay the fee
but they later learned they could not
our goal is to retire and have
affordable vacations they knew that
that's the leverage they used on us
because i told once i retire i'm going
to have a fixed income he says don't
worry about it
you can buy into this
and for life you can use your annual
your points to pay for the total amount
annual of the annual fees but as for the
contract did you read it we did not read
it we didn't read it yeah because we had
faith after 20 years long ownership with
diamond resorts
you know the salesperson
um you know we trusted him he helped us
before they say they've been billed more
than fifteen hundred dollars a month and
after they did some digging they learned
what their purchase was really worth
it's only worth two thousand dollars the
betty malls filed this police report
alleging diamond resorts fraudulently
obtained their money but they were told
this is a civil matter they also reached
out to the 8 news now i-team we learned
diamond resorts was acquired by hilton
grand vacations last year in 2016
arizona's attorney general announced an
800 thousand dollar settlement with
diamond resorts for consumer restitution
after the state received hundreds of
complaints alleging deceptive sales
practices and we found multiple civil
suits filed against both companies
including one from a former employee who
claimed she was told to lie to potential
customers to close deals
the i-team also checked out a sales
presentation in las vegas from the start
we were told we could not participate
without checking off a box to disclose a
salary brexit i can't do the
presentation unless i say what i mean
yeah it's just part of our quality next
we met with a salesman
then we were shown a video
back to the salesman for under four
thousand points you're in the maldives
you won't pay one nickel in the maldives
when we didn't agree to purchase a time
share he brought his manager my job is
kind of on the finance side not the
financial side
we tried to leave multiple times
trying to figure out what's right for
you guys then when we were brought to
what we were told was quality control
another salesman tried to close the deal
the betty malls say a split second
decision after pressure like this cost
them we want to expose to other
timeshare owners the elderly the ones
who retired to look out we reached out
to hilton ground vacations about the
betia mall's concerns the company sent a
statement which reads in part we value
our owners and understand that
situations occasionally arise we have
been in touch with the family to resolve
their concerns quickly
the betia malls tell me the company is
giving them a refund and canceling their
most recent contracts vanessa murphy
live local now